my favorite part about doing murals is
the opportunity to go reach someone that
usually wouldn't be around me this mural
is called breathe deep and I believe
that you learn your best lessons when
you're not expecting to learn my name is
Fabian Williams I'm an artist working in
the great city of Atlanta I've done over
a dozen murals in the city I came from
advertising and the type of work that I
used to do was primarily to sell
products that you don't need at a
certain point I just kind of felt like I
was using my powers for the wrong
reasons
my work is a mix of race politics and
humor so I painted Martin Luther King
floating up in space pointing down at
you because you have to do to work you
have to realize the dream I've come to
believe that space is wisdom and when I
imagined where someone like Martin
Luther King came from and went back to
it would be space
I chose Hosea because his story is kind
of amazing he was a Purple Heart
recipient he was like the general of the
four People's Campaign under Martin
Luther King he joined the civil rights
movement he did a lot of community
building he did a lot of really great
things the conversation that I'm having
with my work is that we need new leaders
I want someone to walk by one of those
murals and build a connection there's
another Hosea Williams here there's
another Martin Luther King jr. here
they're walking around here if they just
don't know it yet these kids should be
able to get up and walk outside the
house and be inspired
[Music]